welcome to this video coverage for the
third round of the candidates tournament
and in this video I'll look at the game
Sevilla with white gets Kramnik and this
is the dual of the two players who won
in the second round so very important
game obviously if it yeah in case of in
heaven own having a winner this person
with plus two early obviously would have
really good chances in this tournament
let's see what happens once he for so
sweetly deviating he played one year
form as he usually does in the round
before but now we see in English opening
kramnik is going for the symmetrical
with c5 he has tried many defenses
against see 493 this is some no surprise
but it's not his yeah maybe the not a
lot of his main defenses will see a line
that features complete symmetry and now
after g6 d4 yeah white strikes first in
the center just before black erskine is
able to play d5 we have this line and
which is known for for ages really since
the 60s so I guess maybe even before
that there was even a game in the famous
1972 World Championship match between
what we fischer and boris spassky where
Fisher had the white pieces against
Spassky and they played exactly the
slide if i'm not mistaken but here
Spassky I think played something else
I'm not sure I think Abed asics and here
chronic played the move Bishop to e6
what needs to be mentioned is that wide
with Queen d3 is making a prophylactic
move the queen is not so well placed in
the long diagonal of course the bishop
on g7 always a slight problem so wyd
retreats the queen it keeps an eye on
the important c foursquare and pawn and
white can continue with two main ways of
developing the bishop he can't continue
like that or very often he will
fianchetto yeah I don't know Kramnik was
maybe slightly surprised to have this on
the board against swidler and he played
the move from Bishop to e6 that is not
one of the main moves it is played but
not on a regular basis more popular as I
think a six yeah the movie should be six
it offers a pawn white can take on b7
but it is not a very healthy pawn this
is how it unfolds and the main problem
now is that black has lots of pressure
for the pond a big point is that b3
looking rather normal to protect the
pawn is actually giving away b3 and
black regains the porn immediately so
the capture on b7 is not really a really
great white is better off with the
strengthening move and he played Bishop
to d2 to protect the knight on c3 and
connect rooks after Queen c8 taking here
why just played b3 and now when black
went for the exchange here on g2 Roxy
one text takes check and queen c6 check
technically this is a novelty and
they're not a very spectacular one and
it's not an especially a critical
position so it's not the big preparation
or anything the queen is just giving
this check also connecting rooks and
three and now e six yeah this is a move
that might surprise some some spectators
isn't this just weakening the g6 pawn
yeah in fact it is and we see in the
game that chrome neck is getting some
problems with this pawn on the other
hand a problem is also that black always
faces the not very welcoming prospect of
a knight coming to d5 and it's not it's
not very nice to to keep it down if you
want to tolerate this knight on d5 for a
long time you don't have much fun in
this game so if you don't go we six and
wide we'll play 95 you will probably
need to take it and this very often
leads to a very one-sided type of game
just for argument's sake I'll put
something on the board let's say black
play something like that yeah just to
show the general problem white enjoys
control on the seafoam something like
that it's just a very uncomfortable
again for black this is of course very
cooperating black can play play tougher
defense but this is a general problem if
a knight appears on d5 you cannot let it
live they had for a long time so he
decided to play a 6pm it's a bit bit of
one of those cases to be between a rock
and hard place you need to choose one
way of suffering and that black is
already in this situation it's not
really a great argument for a setup I
don't like blacks position to yours it
feels very passive to me but besides
some
maybe the general concept here with
Bishop b6 Quincy 8 i'm not so sure what
advice to give like maybe something like
a six rupee a drug and b5 this kind of
idea maybe this is a better way to
defend what I know is that this this is
a certainty yeah let's put booty form
here ok now this it happened sorry here
I confused myself a bit by by looking at
the wrong line I know it's I thought
white lady for which he which he didn't
do yellow black guy is just suffering
from from lack of space and he does not
have any active play it is solid though
it's still solid white now plays an
interesting maneuver with Queen III
attacking a 7 and preparing a nice we do
paying with rook d3 and now Queen d2
thistle like a lot he managed to put the
Queen behind the rook so that the
pressure on DC was actually worth
something d6 now hangs what is Sam likes
defense if you place a move like Bishop
f8 what will probably just put even more
forces against the pawn he decided to to
cover it with 98 and now he for white
completes this typical maroc see bind
structure that normally only offers
black cam two types of counter play d 5
which is yeah completely unrealistic
here as why does so much on this point
it's never never possible and the other
counter plays of course a possible be
five but also this does not seem to
materialize quickly or yeah any anyway
in here future it is just a very passive
position and thanks would love played
played really good here let's look what
it did I played e5 very direct approach
allowing a possible 94 black of course
cannot take plate 806 to get this g5
news in the mix threatening g5 and after
Bishop retreat black and take on e5 it's
a very human move you want to yeah you
want to break free from this bind but
sweetly is not allowing anything in
place h4 and now look C to D 8 to cover
the weak form 26 yeah this is all very
logical Group D 1 further increasing the
pressure and now exactly here the
question is what should like do you
really have difficulties in making a
move here you cannot of course capture
in any way as you just lose the seven
you cannot play d5 let's say it just
gives the pawn away you don't have any
porn breaks that you that you can play
let's say g5 there's this rookie first
if you play nothing move wyd will
probably play a form and ask the
question again no what what is your move
ahead like black is really close to
being super swamped here yeah player
random movie a white might even improve
further and so you have no no
constructive way to continue black is
terribly passive chronic plata b5 and
after that it's clear that
smitha already has some very good
concrete continuation to pyaar to
transform his some strategical
advantages in the position into
something more tangible which means
material he has a good movie and this is
what he played he played c5 and this is
a strong move of course black now yeah
he needs to take it yes I cannot allow
white to capture of course this is also
highly unpleasant giving wider protected
pass on c5 with those passive pieces
look at this and a for coming that's
really bad so you need to take it and he
took it with the Queen not much choice
and here 94 was played the interesting
thing is in this position after Queen B
6 white now had a very strong move that
i'm not sure why actually swidler did
not play here he could play Bishop to e3
and this is some in fact not so
difficult I mean maybe he thought that
he is selling this position too cheaply
this is possible what it does it
basically wins an exchange black moves
the queen and then there's night c5 and
it turns out that this rook has nowhere
to go and for example something like
that very easy rook a seven maybe I'm
just going to take and d7 is coming just
complete disaster black basically after
sorry this is what what he played like
basically after that needs to give away
the
exchange Dwight can you take age 6 yeah
we take stock here white has one in
exchange for a pawn and considering that
he's quick on the C file this should be
a position that is very close to a win
with the good good technical play black
can continue of course not like he will
resign in next three or four moves but
white is certainly very close to win and
this was a really substantial chance
that swindler I think missed he took on
d6 with the night and yeah it looks nice
just from an optical point of view it
feels like the night on d6 is a good
piece and so on but how exactly do you
make anything out of it and this turns
out to be to be not so easy yeah here in
fact chrome neck played to the move
Bishop to f8 and this would have allowed
white again to get a very substantial
advantage it seems that the move like
that say queen c6 was a bit tougher or
maybe be Queen da this is better yeah
the thing is what he played this was
Bishop I made here White had a
relatively simple but strong
continuation which he rejected for some
reason and this is not H 540 played this
is an ID see form and this is a bit of a
mystery to me because the now the next
moves are completely forced and very
easy to calculate and look the 396 rooty
rooty to black must exchange b-52 and I
think it's very easy to see and you
don't need to be a top top 10 player to
do that that why does is close to
winning here because the pawns here so
weak you simply intended to play night
seven to be 8 and Windows pawns and
white I belief is very very close to
winning it's um I don't actually don't
see how black can save the queen side I
think it's it's it's it's almost to win
I don't see a defense um what what
should like do you stop like you you can
do much let's say this one to make this
Bishop more mobile yeah 97 97 98 and the
problem is Bishop f5 is coming and
something like that yes I believe just a
win for white straight forward it's a
pole and black has no compensation
whatsoever you have 97 also to exchange
the good night iam so what is just just
winning I don't really know why he
rejected 94 maybe he felt that with the
continuation the game he keeps more
pressure on black but that c4 is simply
a good move that very likely would have
one played h5 and now black captured on
d6 and of course this isn't completely
completely a different type of position
now no end game without any account to
play but rather complicated play with
all the heavy pieces on the board
yeah again here's an interesting spot
the position is tricky to play with
limited time we will have around eight
minutes here and it seems that the
relatively best movie has Bishop g7 to
exchange this strong bishop this is what
Kramnik played rook c8 it looks
perfectly logical but it has some some
defects rook see one now and black
unfortunately has nothing better than
exchanging and this again seems to be
rather favorable for white it's simple
to see that this is not working you just
run into a self pin which loses the
bishop so that's not the problem but the
problem is that YTM has further ways of
improving his position one idea that I
had after Queen b7 this was played by
kramnik one idea that a hat is Queen c7
an interesting way to play like takes
and politics and now the ideas look the
eighth and the promotion unfortunately
now g-form saves the day for black it's
a draw yeah Brooke the eighth and c8
queen is some too much so that black
needs to go form a perpetual after check
this that's a draw swivel applied g4
intending Quincy seven and chronic
played before yeah that's a move that
not immediately strikes you as being
very logical but in fact it is this will
have played this one but what again
about Quincy seven now the g4
counterplay is not possible but in fact
black can capture and play Queen B 5
this is the all important point of pawn
to b4 black place this none of this this
counter take on the rook and what
happens if Y just continues rooty to
covering E 226 I'm always looking for
possible counterplay if white now
insists on all that what check like give
the check and now again place a
counter-attack on f3 and it turns out
that this is really a draw my promotes
check check check it is just drawn
before secures the counter play just buy
one move in fact from here on chrome
[ __ ] playin some some fantastic
defensive moves we will see some of that
later before and Quincy falls by just
improving the Queen position and further
strengthening yeah Bishop g7 plate and
white kept the pressure on with Bishop
g3 now Queen B 5 was played yeah here
that's an interesting an interesting
point again I'm here I don't really
understand to be honest why why does not
exchanging this seems at least in my
book to be an almost winning endgame
maybe I'm too optimistic that's possible
um yeah black I think it needs to take
you don't want Y to take so captures and
now i'm not sure what to do ready
Bishop f8 black is terribly passive yeah
the thing is what why does threatening
here is just Bishop d2 and capturing on
before so I think you need to attack d 6
yeah just as a prophylaxis against
bishop to d2 yet here it's not so easy
to say what's why it's best move but
let's say I'm and slow strengthen it
looks like that and then get the King
involved this end game seems to be
excellent for white very close to to win
i believe and surprise that swindler
didn't do that plate Bishop to e1 and
overlooked Queenie five presumably this
is a very strong resource that
introduces night Queenie to check and
this is very important like now it gets
counter play with this all-important
check you should have to Bishop f8 yeah
now I'm Villarreal move 39 they both
didn't have much time left decided to
take the pawn and black plate g5 this is
a very good practical decision to get a
form as a threat its move 39 so it's
clear that you need to play your play
active moves with your time Quincy for
and Queen takes a two yet here 40 moves
have been played so Sevilla now again
had some time on his clock to consider
what's going on and the amazing thing is
look at look what's happening here who
41 Spiller played Queen to c6 after
about seven minutes of calculation and
the amazing thing is it seems that this
move while looking yeah completely
normal and active it turns out that this
move was probably just leading to a draw
and the way how black is drawing now is
one of the the most amazing same things
that I recently have seen it just we see
that we see that in a moment um what
white also could have done he could have
taken before which is probably very very
close to a wide win as you can see that
he's got 21 porn one extra porn he's got
the d6 porn and he's got it oops not
that one he's got the passer than the
beep on and the better structure now the
good points here with the bishop against
some rather weak points on dark squares
um this is from a technical point of
view very close to win if not winning
what I believe is that swidler plate
Quincy 6 because he started to calculate
variations now and he didn't see a
defense and in fact as many as I
mentioned there is only one defense and
what I think is really remarkable that
exactly this single defense that black
has is now happening kramnik played
efore which is an excellent move very
very strong move it attacks the rook if
the Queen takes you get your phone back
and are perfectly okay so white must
take with the pawn and now Queenie to
amazing resource that activates blacks
position enormously if white now takes a
look you just take here and you threaten
efore with check this is a big threat
and also d six eggs so one this is an
immediate immediate to draw actually
yeah Queenie to and what did swear the
plane you played rukka three
a completely normal looking move it puts
pressure on the f pawn on f7 and well
look at this rook where is Luke supposed
to go there's just one move need to take
and now queen e8 you see that f7 s
attacked yeah what should like do he
only has one one playable moves now this
is f six you know check and so he gives
he played e5 sorry we the check is what
I wanted to quickly analyze Bishop g7
and what now for white do you have any
strengthening move if you play a move
like we never fight for example Black
has rook t2 and secures enough counter
play this looks very ugly this
configuration but black simply has too
much play with the two heavy pieces he
played e5 and my guesses when swidler
went for Queen c6 he did calculate this
because it looks relatively normal and
it's not difficult to him to calculate
and I believe that after he five he
thought he would just be winning the big
point is if black now takes the spawn of
course I mean this is check very easy if
black takes the porn white wins
instantly with this check yeah now the
all-important move Bishop takes before
you will take the rook next smooth check
and get to a winning king opponent
gamble because they have the outside
passer here white will easily mop up the
whole King side I believe that this is
what Sevilla had calculated and thought
okay after he 5 i'm just winning but the
amazing thing is black
is a defensive and the defense is that
completely sick move f5 really I don't
I'm completely stunned that this is
possible of course right cannot take
yeah that's a easy to see so what should
why do if you take what the rook check
this is just okay for black yeah I'm not
winning as black but yeah I can easily
force a draw him yeah so what should why
do you don't even have a check in this
position the rook is covering the the g6
square yeah what should you do Sevilla
took on f5 and now next move back ramnik
rook to f6 isn't this rough that
strangest ever defenses don't understand
anything of it it's just great he puts
that on f6 and what is what supposed to
do now I cannot take of course and black
has definite counterplay if you play
move like e6 I'm just going 24 and
threatened g4 you know something like
that check it's just a draw right
absolutely has no move here to were to
continue what should you do if you let
save to move the Queen away I'm just
going to take e5 it's it's absolutely
amazing White has no real move to to
improve here yeah the rook now I've got
plenty of checks it's just a draw
amazingly enough yeah swidler plate
kingi three yeah note that here yet all
played all this rather quickly it's all
it's all forced and here invested quite
quite some minutes to maybe try to find
something maybe there is still some idea
left but
it's it's in vain Queenie form this
secures the draw y term is threatened
with this snow plate Bishop c5 check and
now queen yvonne check is securing the
draw yeah why exactly we can we can look
at this Bishop f2 was played if white
blocks like this may I have this check
and yeah the problem is if you go here
for example i go here take the rook no
check checkmate black even wins here
it's simply amazing Black has enough
resources exactly enough to draw on the
game yeah and what did they do and after
this check valves bishop f2 back to you
for Bishop c5 check we new one and after
this repetition they agreed to draw this
is one of the weirdest draws that I've
ever come across that black you has this
absolutely we add sequins f5 takes rook
f6 this looks completely crazy I mean
the reason why black can actually find
this over the board is that everything
else is just losing so you may be a come
to these moves at some point it's it's
much more difficult to see it from the
white side when you decide to go for
this line you might overlook one of
those only moves and think okay now he
resigns but while he never resigned he
kept on playing them the defensive moves
that were necessary to to hold the
position yes but if you look at the
course of this game this might be a game
where afterwards midler some yeah can be
disappointed yet on more than one
occasion I think the possibility to
secure very substantial advance
advantage if not a win
and of course this would have been
immensely important to to win this game
so it's it's only only a draw and yeah
it's certainly not a bad start for him
but win against ramnik would have been
of course excellent yeah and somewhat of
a lucky escape maybe for Kramnik that
was really something of a coincidence
that there was this miracle defense
other than that he had really big
problems in this game alright hope you
enjoyed it take note that after round
three this round today is a rest day on
Sunday so the next games will be played
only on Monday thanks for watching